thank you you know just what are you
no it's physically because it's always
it's about thanking the people who
helped you go on the journey so making
sure I did before
tremendous success
what was your biggest challenge make
this home and headed to get around her
I mean I suppose it might be you know it
things with you in heaven
a new there to say that it was very
tough to get it made it perfect
challenge is probably getting putting it
together because either people are not
lining up to finance a king speech it
was sooo next event in the UK the film
council the one thing happening there a
number of different partners have made
it possible
in the end the call so happening people
believe in yourself
yeah how do you feel about the reading
of the film for pg-13 rating the the
article i think what's happened is that
the the understand the mpaa said if we
dropped the audio of the thumbs out then
they're winning to reduce pg-13 and they
gave us a kind of preclearance in that
i'm going to see on monday that cycle
comic better they're pretty sweet
tomorrow obviously is it nerve-racking
I'm read any predictions
I think anyone would be in would be at
not in the right mind if they were
nervous at the prospect or possibly
making speeches on community
Oh
second
Terry
it actually came to quite naturally we
didn't we did we get asked about the
lock code we learned that was not be so
much more we learn about the Kickstarter
a glass of X good stuff so fast we found
it helps to stop some how are you I mean
you know see into the success of the
film not only for me but also really
cool and see if the British film being
taxed on the video Council message
action well it's been replaced by the
British Film Institute and the irony is
I believe the things we just going to
make so much money back that I've it
encourages the continued government
support to british film the film and if
so they have they given you any feedback
well i oh you know as good as you know
and I study saw in the papers a couple
of weeks ago that the Queen was reported
to see it people
which was devised about them and then
that sword was wrong the BBC had various
other efforts around the world so I
seaweeds being operated but in the midst
of truth
the film was extremely meticulous in all
the details how did you assemble your
crew and work with them to get the
wonderful look of it all of it is a
mixture people are working interpersonal
and an open collaborators who are being
for a while so Danny curvy by the time
because if he shot Jonathan's European
off
long privilege of alternatives to the
first night last year in numbers I think
when you work with people over a few
years they use it's like a conversation
you pick up in midstream you'll go back
to beginning each time
count each other in person
a few brought
british cinematic smart laughter
continuation of the regency you are the
great there Angela somehow evil sweet
I think I mean you know I always think
about lightly Geneva confusing code
to be so poor that
that's a useful because I grew up
I think I definition or something
healthy shake but it means decision
contact on the success of one movie
things we teach at several local
unchanged for visitors
right here you're going to see the pg-13
come tomorrow but it's all happy about
that is it's something that you stand
behind until I see it's like home so let
me know certainly I'm certainly very
unhappy but the kids in the start seeing
it was a disability
no less than this is that the bees don't
carry the Chandra dark interior
gratified happened under the kids
experience bullying kids on xperia z
talk experiences people connect
and selfishly I think it improves film
today younger oglesby great rivers in
other countries or UK Canada be like a
month of emails paper or do I do
I have early release i have look red
single prediction oil thank you